Hello again friends. I'm Alex Lyon you're
about to do lesson 6 of 7 in this mini-
course. You're almost finished. I'm really happy for you. If you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel, now is the time to do so. Make
sure you visit the homepage for the
channel, click on the subscribe button,
and you start getting notifications for
the course. Let's jump right in.
In our last lesson, we looked at pauses. In this,
lesson 6, we'll look at avoiding fillers.
Concise tip number six is to avoid
fillers. I call it a concise tip because
certainly avoiding fillers is going to
make you more concise. It will also add a
lot to your clarity and to your
confident sound. Fillers drag out and
muddle messages for listeners and fillers
make you sound very unsure of what
you're saying. Here are some common fillers.
Right, sort of, kind of, something like
that. As well as um, uh, you know, so, and.
I know some people that count ums and uhs during presentations. But it's not just
annoying. It also really goes to your
credibility.
There's some research on powerless vs
powerful speech and when listeners in
research situations were shown videos
of speakers who use lots of fillers they
thought they were very unconfident or
powerless in their speech. They'd give the
same speakers a clean script so they would
not use any fillers and the listeners in
the research situation thought wow they
really know what they're talking about.
They're very confident. So you can sound
confident just by getting rid of your
fillers. It's a really important issue to
get after. Strategy one is to identify
your filler habits. These are habits.
Most people have specific fillers that
they use over and over again. I use "kind
of," I used to use that. I also use "so" and
I'm working on that one but I still use
it from time to time. You want to listen
to yourself and pinpoint your specific habits.
Listen to recorded presentations, for
example, or you might even ask a trusted
friend. Hey, do I use any fillers do I say
you know or anything like that? And even
if they don't have an answer for you on
the spot, they'll be able to listen to you
as you move forward. Strategy two is to
replace fillers with pauses. I talked about
this in an earlier lesson how awesome
pauses can sound in the right place.
Some people call fillers "vocalized
pauses." In other words, we should be
pausing but we're filling it in with an
utterance that doesn't need to be there.
Pauses give you time to think but they
also make you sound more confident.
Here we have an earlier example with fillers put in there where pauses should be and
you'll notice how tentative and how
unsure it sounds. So, we have a few items
to cover today and uh and we'll look at our
social media campaign and uh we'll look at uh
our overall growth and uh Erin will take
you know suggestions about changes to
the uh website. If I were to come to your
meeting and speak like this you would
notice instantly that I had lots of
fillers. And I have seen people who are
supposed to be in leadership positions
doing this and listeners, in fact, did
mention, wow, they said um and uh a lot.
This matters to people. What we want to
do is add pauses in those places where
we normally use fillers. And we would say the
word "pause" or "period" in our head like we mentioned in a previous lesson. Pauses
restore that clear, confident sound that
we're going for. And you'll notice that
there are some pauses in the middle here
but they still sound better than the fillers.
So if we were to look at this example
ultimately our goal would be to get rid
of the fillers that are in the middle of
the sentences and only use the pauses
that punctuate our communication in a
desired fashion. We want to avoid fillers.
Our takeaway strategies are to identify
your specific filler habits. You don't do them all.
You just do some and if you isolate your
specific habits you're going to have a much
easier time solving that problem. And
then replace those fillers with actual
pauses. Step one is to practice saying "pause" in your head instead of using fillers.
Up next, we're going to work on confident
nonverbals. That will be our last lesson
and it will
superimpose and thread through all the
other things we've talked about a really
nice way.